Caption: [Applause]
Caption: everyone so if anyone doesn't know me my
Caption: name is Michelle Sanford I work at
Caption: Microsoft and I am also the chairman of
Caption: their ACS in Wi if you don't know what
Caption: that is you should come and talk to me
Caption: afterwards or George who is my vice
Caption: chair or in fact Rebecca who is chairman
Caption: of DD deep earth and is also vice chair
Caption: I would say thanks to our amazing
Caption: sponsors of which Microsoft is one of
Caption: them and so is ace yes but we couldn't
Caption: really 1 DDD worth if it wasn't for all
Caption: of them but it has doubled in numbers
Caption: every single year it's it's so exciting
Caption: and I'm hoping next year it will be at
Caption: house and because there were eight
Caption: hundreds of trying to register for this
Caption: one today okay so I started this journey
Caption: by seeing something about the hundred
Caption: days of Cade challenge and I thought
Caption: could I raise a robot army if I had no
Caption: instruction and no prior knowledge and
Caption: the only thing that I knew was I needed
Caption: to spend an hour a day in the code this
Caption: is my this is the story how possible is
Caption: so I I did the first thing I asked the
Caption: internet how to do it it turns out that
Caption: I am not the only one asking the
Caption: internet that and also the cheapest way
Caption: to raise a robot army is to just pay
Caption: like a couple hundred dollars and you
Caption: can get an army of Russian bots to help
Caption: you they go over the world
Caption: so that's one way I didn't go with that
Caption: well we'll go with what I went with
Caption: so with Fight Club
Caption: the first rule of Fight Club is you
Caption: don't talk about Fight Club and the
Caption: second rule of Fight Club is that you
Caption: don't talk about Fight Club that is not
Caption: the case with hundred days of code there
Caption: are only two rules but they are kind of
Caption: the opposite to that so what that means
Caption: is you have a lot of freedom to do
Caption: everyone with your hundred days a lot of
Caption: people were scared of the hundred days
Caption: of code website and it will point them
Caption: at free code camp and so you can start
Caption: just following those tutorials and at
Caption: the end of your hundred days you will be
Caption: a phone and web developer which is a
Caption: pretty good outcome but I kind of
Caption: thought I want to do I want to do
Caption: something with BOTS and I want to do
Caption: something with Python so that was all I
Caption: really had in my mind at the start of
Caption: hundred days um
Caption: you don't need a lot to get started
Caption: there were a lot of tools out there that
Caption: will help you just code in a web browser
Caption: and will give you a sandbox and you can
Caption: do all sorts of tutorials without
Caption: setting anything up at all but if you
Caption: want to really do something these are
Caption: kind of what I found is the the basis so
Caption: I need to get hub Visual Studio code and
Caption: Heroku there's all free so you have to
Caption: pay anything then you do not have to use
Caption: those particular ones but they are
Caption: probably the most common but you know
Caption: there are a lot of the options out there
Caption: these are what I what I really liked and
Caption: what I used so the first rule of hundred
Caption: a decade is you have to spend an hour a
Caption: day in the code and initially when I was
Caption: pretty new to coding I thought how am I
Caption: going to spend an hour in the code is
Caption: going to be too long
Caption: and I thought well I'd better find
Caption: something that will help me track
Caption: whether I've spent an hour so I built
Caption: this little thing and it just tells me
Caption: the key coding until an hour of gotten
Caption: and then at the end it says stop coding
Caption: it's not super accurate so you know
Caption: you'd probably be better looking at your
Caption: watch but if you let it go like this you
Caption: will definitely have done more than an
Caption: hour in the code because it will it will
Caption: probably sort of pause more than it will
Caption: speed up like you won't speed up the
Caption: second rule is that you should tweet
Caption: your progress every day so in the
Caption: beginning you kind of feel stupid
Caption: because you think I haven't done
Caption: anything or what I've done is all gone
Caption: wrong or what I've done make no sense or
Caption: you know all of that stuff and you're
Caption: just kind of you're tweeting out and
Caption: you're just thinking but the hub
Caption: community is really very supportive and
Caption: they will you will get many retweets for
Caption: those things that have the hashtag
Caption: hundred days okay dinner and you will
Caption: get some people to eating back at you
Caption: saying keep at it well done you know
Caption: keep going which is really nice I think
Caption: as I went on I found that the more
Caption: useful thing to do would be to if you
Caption: make mistakes you should share those
Caption: mistakes so that people don't feel like
Caption: when they look at your Instagram feel
Caption: Instagram feed it's just a beautiful
Caption: perfect life where all your coding is
Caption: glorious but you should also when you do
Caption: have glorious code you should also tweet
Caption: about that too because you want to
Caption: celebrate successes as well as laughs
Caption: for your own mistakes
Caption: so there are only two rules and hundred
Caption: ISO code but there are some more things
Caption: that are not exactly rules um give
Caption: before shoutouts is one of them so when
Caption: someone has helped you of something or
Caption: when you've seen something that you
Caption: think is really good then he should you
Caption: should read about that too so I learned
Caption: a lot about Python from Nina she brought
Caption: up her from and they she put up her
Caption: iPhone courses fundamentals and
Caption: intermediate on front-end masters for
Caption: free for I don't know how long like 14
Caption: days or something so I got through most
Caption: of those before the free period ran out
Caption: and then by the time it was into the
Caption: free period I thought I'm gonna buy a
Caption: subscription the front landmasses
Caption: because her courses were so good and you
Caption: want to know if you're going to invest
Caption: in yourselves you want to know that the
Caption: training you're investing in is worth
Caption: something so if you find something like
Caption: that then share that and say that you
Caption: think it's good so there are only two
Caption: rules in a hundred rules of a hit but
Caption: there are more things the first thing I
Caption: discovered is that you really need to
Caption: have a plan because otherwise you start
Caption: on day one and you don't know what you
Caption: do at all it bit me like the whole day
Caption: the whole day Saturday to just download
Caption: Python and all of the libraries and all
Caption: of the extra things that you needed and
Caption: yes I thought I'm not going to record
Caption: that as day one or recorder as day zero
Caption: and and then later on I realized that
Caption: recording it as Daisy reg was a more
Caption: programmatic thing to do um I mentioned
Caption: using gear up earlier and when I first
Caption: started using github I didn't really
Caption: know what it was apart from it seemed
Caption: like a really cool thing to me and I
Caption: knew that Microsoft had bought it so
Caption: but it's probably worth something um
Caption: luckily when you don't know how to use
Caption: github they have a bot that will teach
Caption: you how to use github and I thought well
Caption: this is good because I want to learn
Caption: about books and the body is gonna teach
Caption: me do so he will teach you for free and
Caption: then after you have learnt how to use
Caption: github from the but you could actually
Caption: learn how to build a bot of your own
Caption: using github as well so I did the first
Caption: ones I learned were at github bots that
Caption: sort of reply to comments and things
Caption: like that it's pretty cool oh yeah that
Caption: whole the repo and commit the look
Caption: thing yeah that was that was like a
Caption: foreign language first of all when I
Caption: heard someone's like that where they
Caption: just go into github and walk my repo and
Caption: then you'll be fine and I was just like
Caption: what yeah I mean it's super easy I do
Caption: that idea the forking all the time now
Caption: yeah I wrote a thing about this because
Caption: this is this is important so is it
Caption: developed for its best practice not only
Caption: to anticipate what also to prepare for
Caption: errors so we're not usually done through
Caption: some sort of mechanism typically called
Caption: a fallback and most programming
Caption: languages have some sort of key word
Caption: along the lines of try and catch so the
Caption: logic being dry some code and if that
Caption: doesn't work ouch the error and then
Caption: handle it for your user so you're you
Caption: fall back to that error handling case um
Caption: I wanted to have a fun full back a from
Caption: default in case I got home from work and
Caption: fell exhausted and like I didn't want to
Caption: spend an hour in a code and that was
Caption: very often the case
Caption: so what we have here is Kate combats how
Caption: many of you have played this not many
Caption: how many of you have kids well all of
Caption: you that kids definitely play this and
Caption: all of you that don't have kids should
Caption: definitely play this is a platformer it
Caption: doesn't work it's not an app it's a web
Caption: thing so you can't really do it from
Caption: your phone but you can do it from your
Caption: laptop you can do it for free first of
Caption: all for a lot levels I paid the $99
Caption: lifetime subscription because it has
Caption: hundreds and hundreds of apples and four
Caption: different worlds and you can go through
Caption: the whole thing to learn Python and then
Caption: you can wipe it and go back to the start
Caption: and learn the whole thing in JavaScript
Caption: so it's definitely worth it it teaches
Caption: you to code by playing a game so like
Caption: first one that you try is just like one
Caption: line and then it's two lines of code and
Caption: then it's three lines of code this is
Caption: obviously a very simple code but like
Caption: really really long and as you progress
Caption: it incentivizes you to shut down your
Caption: code so that instead of it being like 20
Caption: or 30 lines there if you could do it in
Caption: five lines that would give you a high
Caption: reward
Caption: but it doesn't expect you to do that at
Caption: the beginning so it's it's very nice and
Caption: it sort of wines on your brain other one
Caption: is solar learn that is an app you can
Caption: get on your phone and you can play that
Caption: you know when you're walking along the
Caption: street when you're on your commute not
Caption: if you're the driver but if you only
Caption: really know something other passenger
Caption: and it's not as much fun as Kade combat
Caption: but it is it does have like little tests
Caption: and challenges and things so it teaches
Caption: you basics this one I did have it
Caption: playing the beautiful music
Caption: what's it from gravity my children's
Caption: wicked from wicked yeah but it's not
Caption: playing it for us now but anyway yeah
Caption: why did I choose Python is this because
Caption: it's magic is one of the reasons because
Caption: it's symbol because it's fun because it
Caption: comes with batteries included so that's
Caption: like they they say to sort of summarize
Caption: it has a little libraries built in so
Caption: that you can do stuff without actually
Caption: writing all the code for it and also it
Caption: has hidden easter s in it so this one of
Caption: the easter eggs if you type in port and
Caption: gravity from the command line it brings
Caption: up this little cartoon there what I
Caption: learned was that there were pretty much
Caption: two kinds of jackpot that you could
Caption: build there's one that sort of rules
Caption: based and it follows the rules those
Caption: rules can get like complex or it can be
Caption: very simple and then there's ones that
Caption: will learn for themselves so I started
Caption: from the very beginning weird scratch
Caption: which is what kids learn from when
Caption: you're seven years of age you could
Caption: learn scratch and I thought I should
Caption: learn how to make a look at what in that
Caption: the the blocks teach kids the logic of
Caption: coding and so it's sort of a when
Caption: someone clicks this then you do that
Caption: when someone says this then you do that
Caption: and just sing the blocks clarifies in
Caption: their mind how coding really works and
Caption: they can move straight from scratch into
Caption: Python which is what I wanted to go so I
Caption: thought I'll start there so this is a
Caption: Snickers playing with Cody blocky
Caption: I thought I should have a actual
Caption: physical but in order to really
Caption: satisfies the robot army thing so I
Caption: brought Cody blocky on the internet and
Caption: it is something that you can program
Caption: with again these Cody blocks or you can
Caption: also then switch over to Python and
Caption: teach it to do more complex stuff using
Caption: that Snickers was pressing the button
Caption: there and when she presses the button it
Caption: when's the gate she was doing that
Caption: pretty old there but later on my hand
Caption: are just chewing the bar which so I made
Caption: a thicker box which is modeled on
Caption: Snickers if you how many of you have to
Caption: go if you find her on Twitter right now
Caption: you could tweet her so her thing is at
Caption: BOTS liquor and if you tweet her using
Caption: either the hashtag DDD Perth or what's
Caption: rising then she should reply to you if
Caption: you do not have the hashtags in there
Caption: she will not reply to you if you put
Caption: both of them in there that would be okay
Caption: it doesn't drive her crazy I have tested
Caption: that this morning if you reply on one of
Caption: the relies or one of the tweets that
Caption: also doesn't drive her crazy we're
Caption: totally fine so yeah feel free to tweet
Caption: and she will hopefully tweet back all
Caption: going well she does sometimes go rogue
Caption: but generally generally not today I hope
Caption: because I didn't want our scattering
Caption: work so I didn't leave her just running
Caption: generically in the cloud I have earned
Caption: my control right here I
Caption: so I initially got the basic paid for
Caption: that buy from this guy he has a really
Caption: nice video that taught me how to build
Caption: my first Twitter bot and yeah it's a
Caption: really nice video and its really clear
Caption: and its really explicit and even though
Caption: I think it's more than a year old it
Caption: still works which is a problem with code
Caption: and with cloud a lot of stuff that you
Caption: follow in tutorials is out of date in
Caption: about five seconds but this one's good
Caption: one so this is their code
Caption: that pretty much the code that I used
Caption: and no in fact that is the whole program
Caption: so it doesn't need any more than that to
Caption: run that Twitter bot so all it does here
Caption: is when you tweet to it
Caption: she will reply with hi your Twitter name
Caption: meister tweet you or just you know one
Caption: little sentence the keys for the Twitter
Caption: bot are in the code those are not my
Caption: keys there's some police that was one of
Caption: the things I found really confusing in
Caption: the beginning because people would put
Caption: you know insert your keys here and I was
Caption: like does that include the quote marks
Caption: around it how do I know
Caption: does the keys look like this is this
Caption: what its effecting anyway they look like
Caption: that they look exactly like that but
Caption: different you know because that's not
Caption: like those times at the top import TWiki
Caption: and in poor time those are the two
Caption: libraries that it uses so 3p kind that
Caption: tells it how to do the stuff with
Caption: Twitter and time is literally for this
Caption: one little bit at the bottom where it
Caption: says hold off for 15 seconds because if
Caption: your bot tweets rapidly Twitter will
Caption: shut you
Caption: so you have to make her pause so all
Caption: it's doing really atop its saying
Caption: there's the there's the keys he
Caption: authenticated gainst Twitter it didn't
Caption: used to do that so there's a lot of
Caption: tutorials that don't explain the
Caption: authentication part and then of course
Caption: you can't get anything working if he
Caption: don't have that in and then but last no
Caption: ID that is to stop it going crazy like
Caption: she often does when she's in the loud
Caption: and just forgetting that she's already
Caption: replied to your tweet and replying to
Caption: your same tweet like 50 times more so it
Caption: should take the ID of the last week that
Caption: it saw store that in a file and then
Caption: check that before sending a reply to a
Caption: tweet and then in this there it is just
Caption: saying look for the hashtag when you see
Caption: so here it's hashtag Snickers respond
Caption: back with hi at and then nice to tweet
Caption: so it's it really pretty simple if
Caption: anyone is worried that about following
Caption: the tutorials I do have they get help
Caption: with the instructions on there so you
Caption: don't really need to make any notes okay
Caption: so then after I've done that I thought I
Caption: will learn how to get it running through
Caption: the cloud because otherwise it's just
Caption: running on your your desktop and when
Caption: your desktop is down and you're good
Caption: about is down so I initially looked at
Caption: Azure because I'm working at Microsoft
Caption: and you know use Azure there are a lot
Caption: of choices in there a lot of things you
Caption: can do there's a lot of traces and when
Caption: you are in your first 30 days of code
Caption: you will be confused by all of the
Caption: options you have so I found then who oq
Caption: is the path system which will then all
Caption: you need to do in Heroku is sort of
Caption: click on the button that says create new
Caption: app and
Caption: then attach or load your code into it
Caption: and that's pretty much it so it's it's
Caption: super super easy live with no traces oh
Caption: yeah there are other clouds available of
Caption: course however after I was more than 30
Caption: days and I did go back
Caption: Asya to see what else I could do and
Caption: there's a yeah there's really a lot of a
Caption: lot of fun things you can do in there
Caption: that you can't do just on your own weave
Caption: code and with a path system and here
Caption: what I was looking at is connecting the
Caption: different channels so yeah you can
Caption: connect it to Facebook or to Skype or to
Caption: teams or yeah Twilio or like a million
Caption: other things and more of those will
Caption: probably appear over time I only learn
Caption: so you connect it to Facebook quite
Caption: recently but I was very impressed with
Caption: myself and I did what you can see down
Caption: this side all of these resources were
Caption: all the other things I was learning to
Caption: do with the bots so I did some stuff
Caption: we're sort of facial recognition and
Caption: cognitive services back it could
Caption: recognize my dogs and it could sort of
Caption: recognize are they a shih tzu or are
Caption: they not ETSU I've had a very a dog
Caption: still or not a dog I'm specifically are
Caption: they leo
Caption: Snickers or shoo shoo or are they some
Caption: other dog and I did put some of their
Caption: friends and that kind of like Alsatians
Caption: and kelpies that are completely
Caption: different from small fluffy dogs and it
Caption: could pick those out too so that was
Caption: yeah that's pretty cool there's once
Caption: you're confident with what you're doing
Caption: there's a lot of fun stuff that you can
Caption: plug into it if some of those are the
Caption: lowest stuff as well so these bots that
Caption: I'm showing you today are all kind of
Caption: dumbots but you can make a smart
Caption: by using the language stuff oh I did
Caption: have some really funny videos me just
Caption: making faces at the camera where I was
Caption: using sentiment analysis so yeah there's
Caption: really a lot of cool things you can do
Caption: once she start learning about the bots
Caption: so back to the snica bots this was kind
Caption: of a better bot so she's a little bit
Caption: better than the initial Cinco bot is
Caption: this one the first thing that I was
Caption: super pleased with myself about was not
Caption: having the keys in the code so the first
Caption: step after having keys in the code is
Caption: actually putting the keys in a different
Caption: file and then having git ignore those
Caption: keys so that it doesn't publish them on
Caption: github and this is the next step after
Caption: that where you don't have the key in the
Caption: code at all you tell it to look in the
Caption: cloud system that you're running it
Caption: through so you load them in as operating
Caption: system environment variables and it's
Caption: kind of like it's just a space in there
Caption: where you fill those in and then there
Caption: that tells it to look for there but that
Caption: means that you need more lines at the
Caption: top so where it says import to be in
Caption: port time that we had before you also
Caption: need import OS and the OS is the thing
Caption: that's going to know about those
Caption: operating system variables and then I
Caption: have import random because I'm gonna
Caption: have it if you random access to your
Caption: tweets so from a file called messages
Caption: that I have created separately so then
Caption: it does pretty much the same thing as it
Caption: did before but depending on what hashtag
Caption: you use it does a different thing so if
Caption: you do if you do DDD perf it will give
Caption: you answer from one vial and if you do
Caption: rising robots it will give you an answer
Caption: from another file and it will if you do
Caption: Snickers I don't kill all just do the
Caption: same one-liner that it was doing
Caption: previously if it's kind of using if
Caption: statements and early statements and just
Caption: before I figured out that if I put some
Caption: breaks in there then it wouldn't go
Caption: crazy when when it found unexpected
Caption: stuff that is pretty happy with that so
Caption: then this is this the next one I found
Caption: really useful this one is a blog on the
Caption: Twilio website and from there I used how
Caption: to make the bots into a Facebook but
Caption: instead of a Twitter BOTS so it's not I
Caption: can't figure out how to make Facebook
Caption: make the bots public they just keep
Caption: rejecting I bought but it doesn't for me
Caption: so I'm typing in blue and it's sending
Caption: responses there this one it eases yeah I
Caption: should have had my glasses on I can't
Caption: see what what I used there oh yeah
Caption: that's using flask so this is using
Caption: flask which is a slightly different web
Caption: front-end the night breeze least and
Caption: yeah all that stuff in the middle is
Caption: related to the Facebook thing and it is
Caption: getting these so it also has similar a
Caption: similar kind of messages file that it
Caption: takes this off on but the one that he
Caption: had written in the tutorial he said
Caption: would just be a
Caption: like a like a nice but the goal was for
Caption: it to just weed out nice things from it
Caption: and that was what I used for my template
Caption: for this one then I thought I would like
Caption: to be a little bit spotter so I tried
Caption: this as your tutorial this one only
Caption: takes 45 minutes 48 minutes to do and it
Caption: uses Q&A maker so what I liked about
Caption: this is that you could load up a whole
Caption: bunch of information like from wiki or
Caption: something like that
Caption: so if you were running a helpdesk you
Caption: could when they're like you could run
Caption: your know your have the scripts through
Caption: it but it would also learn so from the
Caption: fact that you are having questions and
Caption: answers with it it will then from those
Caption: so and can train it within their the Q&A
Caption: maker thing after that you could then go
Caption: in and incorporate some Louis stuff in
Caption: it as well so it could look at your
Caption: intense and it could try and form
Caption: answers based on what it thought we're
Caption: trying to ask so this is so built in
Caption: Asia and that's the web test there but
Caption: then in order different and I learn it
Caption: again through the same facebook
Caption: messenger thing and so this one it asks
Caption: it knows about bots and you can ask it
Caption: questions about bots and will answer
Caption: questions about bots but if you ask you
Caption: something else
Caption: that is not about what it will still
Caption: answer and there were things in there
Caption: that I didn't put in there that it
Caption: answered but I only really notice them
Caption: other people were playing with it
Caption: because obviously in my head I knew once
Caption: questions to ask it and then I asked my
Caption: husband have a look and he said what is
Caption: your name oh god I never thought anyone
Caption: would ask it what his name is when I
Caption: said a skit about BOTS but it said what
Caption: is in a name
Caption: and I felt that's very philosophical it
Caption: had to see surprising answers like that
Caption: so yeah that's that's a fun thing to do
Caption: play with so Waveland this is the from
Caption: the tutorial on the trio website and it
Caption: said if you want to create a
Caption: requirements document requirements mile
Caption: you can just type pip three freeze
Caption: greater than requirements text and you
Caption: will have a file that looks like this
Caption: and then my file look like that
Caption: I might've but it turned out that's
Caption: totally fine
Caption: it's the reason it's like that is
Caption: because I have you know installed
Caption: everything in world because I didn't
Caption: know what I might meet and I might not
Caption: meet and all of these things look good
Caption: so yeah there's more than I need there
Caption: you can cut them out as well so if you
Caption: know that your your code is only using
Caption: flask and it's not using Django as well
Caption: which obviously it wouldn't be you can
Caption: take out all of the stuff and just put
Caption: things in its definitely needing the
Caption: advantage of having those in the
Caption: requirements file is that when you try
Caption: to write in the cloud it will learn
Caption: correctly on white versions and it won't
Caption: you know era that there's a lot of free
Caption: tutorials out there that was one of the
Caption: things I don't go did you know I bought
Caption: some they brought front and web masses
Caption: which was really good and I bought the
Caption: code combat thing but also a lot of
Caption: things that I follow for free were
Caption: really really good as well I do
Caption: recommend that will year one because not
Caption: just the great logs but the learn how to
Caption: use it by playing a game thing really
Caption: appeals to me as a gamers in the
Caption: audience
Caption: a few yeah it's super fun they've just
Caption: released a like a full game version on
Caption: early access which I'm completely
Caption: addicted to already ah also learn that
Caption: if you don't know what to do you can
Caption: just ask you can ask the community you
Caption: can tweet it out and people will tweet
Caption: back at you and tell you what the answer
Caption: is Phil gave me a lot of answers and
Caption: didn't make me feel stupid at all and
Caption: not just feel like a lot of people when
Caption: when something goes wrong and you just
Caption: can't figure it out and you're about to
Caption: cry then just tweet and you know and
Caption: people will help you and no one ever
Caption: says that was a stupid question or if
Caption: they do you're yeah if you do you're in
Caption: the wrong place don't follow those
Caption: people anymore look away from them this
Caption: is morbid advice from Nina in that you
Caption: don't feel it it was at the start of
Caption: your hundred days of code you really
Caption: feel like you don't know anything but I
Caption: should go on you start to feel like you
Caption: really know and the stuff that was so
Caption: hard at the beginning becomes really
Caption: obvious but it is practice it isn't an
Caption: innate talent that was born in in the
Caption: developer guts it's lil again helping me
Caption: sometimes it really isn't anything so a
Caption: lot of the times it was a stupid syntax
Caption: error in your code but sometimes you do
Caption: just turn it off and on again and
Caption: suddenly it works
Caption: and feels that that happens to him all
Caption: the time too so here is where I have
Caption: documented the tutorial so it is a
Caption: github repository called rise of the
Caption: robots and in there's a code directory
Caption: in that way you can get code and there
Caption: is also a Doc's directory where I have
Caption: this first document it's not yeah it's
Caption: not yet perfect in that I see that I
Caption: just said you know go to the go with the
Caption: Twitter app developer paid and just fill
Caption: that stuff in that isn't enough if it's
Caption: your first time to Twitter app developer
Caption: page because you're looking all the
Caption: things to fill in and you're thinking
Caption: what do I bring there so I will put a
Caption: screenshot of what that looks like so
Caption: that people can see it it's just that
Caption: when you try to make the documentation
Caption: it's super boring from the good
Caption: documentation I followed I realized that
Caption: the most explicit documentation is the
Caption: best documentation and so the best thing
Caption: that I can do for those that come after
Caption: me it's like really explicit
Caption: documentation I will improve it
Caption: however it would also like to help me do
Caption: that do you feel free to you know
Caption: that we pay and make up all requests
Caption: yeah now add more in there as I carry on
Caption: because I will not stop at the hundred
Caption: days I think there's still so much more
Caption: to learn and so many so many things I
Caption: was distracted by a long way so yeah I
Caption: don't have up a robot on me I only have
Caption: to be robots currently of maybe four and
Caption: it's not enough to take over the world
Caption: so I don't have to keep going beyond the
Caption: hundred days those your eyes wait close
Caption: your eyes close your eyes close your
Caption: eyes and I'll just read you the poem so
Caption: beautiful is better than ugly explicit
Caption: is better than implicit symbol is better
Caption: than complex complex is better than
Caption: complicated what is better than nested
Caption: sparse is better than dense readability
Caption: counts special cases aren't special
Caption: enough to break the rules
Caption: although practicality beats purity Alice
Caption: should never have silently unless
Caption: explicitly silenced in the face of
Caption: ambiguity refuse the temptation gasps
Caption: there should be one and probably only
Caption: one obvious way to do it or there that
Caption: way may not be obvious at first
Caption: unless you're Dutch now is better than
Caption: ever
Caption: although never is often better than
Caption: right now
Caption: if implementation is hard to explain
Caption: it's a bad idea if the implementation is
Caption: easy to explain it may be a good idea
Caption: namespaces are one honking great idea
Caption: let's do more of those so it can open
Caption: eyes is one of the other eat Easter eggs
Caption: from Python so when you type import this
Caption: it brings up this poem which is known as
Caption: the Zen of Python and it is a relief
Caption: when you code like this you code
Caption: pythonic Lee is is what they say so I
Caption: really like it because it's though all
Caption: these beautiful little tricks but if you
Caption: type it again import this it won't bring
Caption: it up a second line it'll bring it up
Caption: only the first time okay and then we're
Caption: done
Caption: you